In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for June 3, on which we commemorate the Holy Martyr
Lucilian of Nicomedia and those with him.
On the third of the month we celebrate the memory of the Holy Martyr's Lucilian and
the four children, Claudius, Epatius, Paul and Dionysius and of the Holy Martyr, Paula.
In the time of Emperor Aurelion, it was reported to Sylvanus, governor of Nicomedia, that the
number of citizens abandoning the cults of Zeus and Hermes to embrace the Christian faith
was growing in a disquieting way, especially as the temple priest Lucilian had joined them
and had two years earlier stopped offering sacrifice to the gods for the peace of the Empire.
Beside himself with fury Sylvanus ordered that the necessary preparations be made for sacrifice
and promised the rank of first dignitary of his Praetorium to whomever would bring Lucilian
to him.
A Jew, called Simeon, for a large sum of money revealed the place where the saint was
accustomed to meet with others of the faithful, two miles from the town.
A strong detachment was sent to arrest them and put them in prison.
After a night kept apart from his companions, Lucilian appeared the next morning before Sylvanus
in the Agora.
When the governor told him severely with the threat of terrible torture to renounce the
crucified and return to the cult of the gods, publicly offering them the sacrifice that
was their due, the saint replied, I will never abandon the hope I have found in Christ,
to sacrifice to lifeless stones and impure demons.
I have lost enough years in serving them in vain, inflict on me what you will as soon as possible.
Nothing can make me change.
On the governor's orders the soldiers lacerated his face and thrashed him for two hours, stretched
out on the ground between four stakes and then hung him head downwards.
Lucilian, however, remained insensible to the suffering and treated the governor as a servant
of Satan and an enemy of God destined for Gehenna.
On the recommendation of a philosopher called Christmas, who advised Sylvanus to make an end as quickly
as possible for fear that the martyr's resistance should produce other conversions, he sent him back
to prison.
In his cell, Lucilian found four children, Claudius, Epateus, Paul and Dionysius, who had
been imprisoned for their faith.
Seeing him, the children fell at his feet, asking him to pray that it might be given to them
to receive the incorruptible wreath of martyrdom.
Early in the morning they were all five taken to the temple of Aries.
Lucilian was seated there and ordered them to sacrifice to the gods under the threat
of being cast into the fire.
St. Lucilian reiterated his ardent confession, declaring that he had nothing to fear from
a fire of short duration, while he, Sylvanus, would have to endure eternal fire.
The children echoed his words and declared that they knew only how to pray to the father,
son and Holy Spirit.
Furious to discover that even children could resist with such valor, Sylvanus ordered that
they all be thrown into the flames.
But at the prayer of the saints, as happened in ancient times in Babylon, for the three young
men, a heavenly shower came and put the fire out, and they stood there, praising God.
Lucilianus had them taken to Calcedon to attempt to have them sacrifice to Zeus, promising
the children rich presence and luxurious clothes.
But they replied with one voice, may your honors go with you to perdition.
The tyrant angered beyond measure, then had them taken to Byzantium, where the four children
were beheaded, and St. Lucilian crucified in a desert place.
They banged nails into his head, chest, knees and genitals.
A young and devout virgin called Paula, who had secured the saints during their imprisonment
in spite of repeated prohibitions and threats from the pagans, was then denounced to Count
Sylvanus.
Arrested in Nicomedia, she appeared in front of the governor and confessed that she had
been brought to the faith by the glorious Lucilian.
Beaton with thongs by six men taking turns, she sang, all day long have I been punished,
but thou, Lord, art my strong refuge.
As she remained unshakable, he had her beaten with cuddles, until her limbs were all broken.
But at her prayer an angel came and healed her and assured her that in heaven Lucilianus
and four child martyrs were praying for her, that she would be confirmed in the faith.
She was taken again before Sylvanus, radiant and full of courage, and made it clear to him,
that she was in a hurry to carry off in her turn the trophies of victory.
After having broken her jaw, he threw her back into prison, cast into the flames she
was kept untouched by the intervention of an angel, and then taken to the vicinity
of Byzantium she was beheaded, giving thanks to God, on the same spot which Saint Lucilian
had been martyred, through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God,
have mercy on us and save us.